America is the great land of reinvention
I mean it's that if there's a consistent
and the thing that makes it so so great
is that it was reinvented by successive
generations both you know from from the
the immigrant experience the frontier
experience the most of us are not
descendants of the the original
colonists but of of people who came to
one way or another to make themselves a
better in different life and it's always
been an innovative there are negatives
too I mean one of the things I ran about
in my book is the extent to which still
America's life is warped by the legacy
of slavery the original sin of our
country but you know with all advanced
countries that have a lot in common
America has its virtues its defects but
what strikes me is actually how similar
in a way the choices the dilemmas the
positive things are and across across
the advanced world or not we're not
we're not that exception